the pulse of blinding light the red hot
Fireball and the column of superheated
gases Rising miles into the atmosphere
as it rains down radiation below these
are the events that unfold after the
detonation of an atom bomb in this video
I'll take a closer look at each stage of
this catastrophic event and understand
what happens and why this is the dark
science of a nuclear
explosion
[Music]
2 1
t0 in detonation a subcritical mass of
either uranium 235 or plutonium 239 is
imploded by a chemically initiated
explosion this explosion condenses the
radioactive core into itself creating an
unstable super critical iCal Mass when
struck with a neutron this supercritical
Mass detonates when a radioactive nuclei
is struck with the neutron it splits
into radioactive isotopes and free
neutrons these neutrons then strike
other nearby radioactive nuclei causing
them to split and release neutrons thus
creating a chain reaction however if the
density of the uranium core is too low
or subcritical neutrons will strike very
few nuclei as they are to spread out as
a result a chain reaction cannot occur
this this is why just before the core is
shot with neutrons it's forcefully
imploded into itself implosion increases
the density of the core pushing the
nuclei closer together to make a chain
reaction more conducive when the density
of nuclei is high enough to cause a
chain reaction it's known as a super
critical
mass the energy from the kinetic split
of atomic nuclei releases an immense
amount of energy so much that electrons
are energized to the point of emitting
several bands of electromagnetic
radiation this emission consists of
visible light ultraviolet light X-ray
and gamma rays and appears as a pulse of
blinding light that lasts for a tenth of
a second emission of light by excited
electrons is called spontaneous emission
and is a known phenomenon whenever
electrons absorb energy they jump to a
higher energy orbit in their atomic
Arrangement and then return back to a
lower orbit while doing so they emit a
form of radiation in between infrared
and gamma rays for example when you pass
electricity through a Tungsten filament
in a light bulb the temperature of 4,600
fit causes emission of visible light
from the electromagnetic spectrum the
more energy the electron absorbs the
higher frequency radiation it emits for
example the heat from splitting a
radioactive nuclei is over 100 million
de F this temperature excites electrons
so much that they emit UV X-ray and
gamma radiation that is initially 2.5
times brighter than the sun the
intensity of this radiation can cause
flash blindness and burns to the eyes
and skin this is footage from operation
upshot knole gravel where a 15 kiloton
atom bomb was detonated this army
vehicle was placed approximately 3,000
ft or a little over half a mile from
Ground Zero upon detonation heat from
the emission of high energy X-ray and
gamma radiation vaporizes the paint off
the vehicle this illustrates just how
destructive it is to human skin
little boy had a blast yield of 15
kilotons yet it still caused significant
Burns as far away as 2.5 mil from Ground
[Music]
Zero the sustained splitting of atomic
nuclei produces temperatures and
pressures comparable to the interior of
the Sun in an area no longer than 10 ft
air is quickly ionized creating a
superheated plasma producing a massive
Fireball that expands to a diameter of
half a mile a spherical Fireball is
formed because explosions expand equally
in all three dimensions forming a ball
of superheat and
[Music]
plasma heat from the expanding Fireball
causes air arounded to rapidly heat up
and expand outward at supersonic
speeds the front of the blast wave
called the shock front moves a wall of
compressed air at speeds of 7 180 mph
destroying and throwing anything in its
path the initial shock wave weakens
structures and disperses air in the
immediate area causing a void the
surrounding air then rapidly rushes back
in which tears the weaken structure into
pieces the compression vacuum and blast
winds together May exert forces stronger
than a level five hurricane research
from Japanese surveys after the
Hiroshima and Nagasaki events found that
winds traveling at roughly 200 94 mph
was enough to destroy wooden buildings
severely damage cement structures and
cause human lungs to
collapse after the fireball to forms
into hot gases and fiery clouds the
heated Mass Rises as it's less dense
than the air around it similar to a hot
air balloon however there are denser
gases above the heated gases that are
trying to rise as the heated gases
Ascend they cause turbulent mixing with
the more dense gases and pull the denser
gases upward with them this creates the
stem of the mushroom cloud and is known
as ra tailor instability this occurs
when a highdensity fluid and a
lowdensity fluid mix together the clouds
at the top have low density while the
clouds in the stem are more dense the
cloud itself has a red Hue from
formation of different oxides of
nitrogen as the heated gases readily
react with nitrogen in the air the
heated gases climb at a rate of about
300 ft per second eventually reaching a
ceiling of 4 to 6 mi in roughly 10
minutes at about 5 m in the atmosphere
temperatures reach as low as -35° F
where water vapor condenses into clouds
the hot gases lose kinetic energy and
condense into water droplets Shifting
the red Hues to a grayish white
producing the characteristic mushroom
cap at the top of the column with no
more heat left to rise the cloud
diffuses horizontally in the atmosphere
[Music]
as the mushroom cloud cools and diffuses
in the atmosphere radioactive isotopes
from the fision reaction descend back to
the
ground nuclear fision of plutonium in
uranium produces over 300 radioisotopes
however common products are strontium 90
cium 137 xenan 135 iodine 131 and barium
14 41 some Isotopes though radioactive
are not a major threat due to short
half-lies for example the halflife of
barium 141 is 18 minutes and Xenon 135
is 9.2 hours some have longer half lives
and therefore pose a serious threat
iodine 131 has a halflife of 8 days
which is moderately long but is nothing
compared to strontium 90's halflife of
29 years or CM 137 of 30 years these
longer Half Lives POS a serious risk as
the radioactive material stays present
for decades increasing the chances of
cancer exposure but even these
radioisotopes don't have the longest
Half Lives despite the magnitude of the
nuclear explosion only a small amount of
the phys plutonium 239 and uranium 235
was used up Batman contained 13.6 lb of
plutonium but only 2 lb or 14% underwent
Vision likewise little boy contained 100
40 lb of uranium 235 with 2.4 lb or 1.7%
undergoing fision the remaining 11.6 lb
of plutonium and 138 lb of uranium was
vaporized and later fell to the ground
with the rest of the Fallout plutonium
239 has a halflife of 24,000 years and
uranium 235 a halflife of 700 million
years cancer surveys conducted in Japan
from exposure to Fallout as late as 1950
found an increase in cancer rates with
stomach lung and liver cancers being the
most
[Music]
common the detonation of a nuclear bomb
instills Beauty awe and Terror the
magnitude of energy and destruction that
follows is a revelation of the power
that lies in the world around us and
whether it be used for good or
evil though the nuclear age has Changed
History we still have yet to see what
future it will
bring thank you for watching Dark
science